[Musique]
les gens veulent savoir d'abord de
personnes expertes et indépendants que
l'intégrité de nos élections obtenus ils
veulent savoir que les différents partis
politiques vont pouvoir mettre au défi
nos systèmes de renseignement pour
assurer qui sont en train de faire tout
ce qui est nécessaire ils veulent aussi
voir publiquement
ces gens questionnés et répondre à des
questions précises sur l'ingérance
chinoise et comment on est en train de
répondre or on a en place actuellement
des mécanismes qui font exactement ça
juste un truc d'eau sur ce que les
Canadiens réclament face aux allégations
de tentatives d'ingérence étrangère aux
élections 2019 et de 2021 le sujet a
dominé cette semaine de pause
parlementaire à Ottawa le Premier
ministre a-t-il été rassurant voyons
voir ce qu'on pense mes collaborateurs
avec Chantal sont absents cette semaine
se joignent à nous Fanny Olivier
affectatrice parlementaire de
Radio-Canada Ottawa alti orange
chroniqueuse au Toronto Star et vous le
connaissez il est avec nous chaque
semaine Michel seoget rencontre
politique à Radio-Canada et à la presse
bonjour à vous trois bonjour je commence
avec vous paniquez ce qu'on a appris
cette semaine de tous ces points de
presse de ces mises à jour du comité
qu'est-ce qu'on a appris sur cette
tentatives d'agence on aurait pu être
rassuré cette semaine par l'apparition
d'un comité d'un rapport qu'on attendait
depuis presque 18 mois le rapport de
Maurice Rosenberg qui nous a appris que
oui il avait bel et bien eu de
l'ingérence en 2021 des ingérence
étrangères mais que ça n'a pas at un
seuil suffisant pour être critique pour
remettre en question l'intégrité des
élections le problème c'est que avant
même l'apparition de ce rapport-là il a
été remis en question la crédibilité de
son rapport de son auteur a été remis en
question parce que Maurice Rosenberg a
été le président de la Fondation Trudeau
de 2014 à 2018 ce qui jette vraiment une
ombre sur le rapport les libéraux
misaient sur ce rapport pour essayer de
remettre un peu le couvercle sur la
marmite ils sont retrouvés avec une un
tout petit couvercle avec une vraiment
très grosse marmite l'adéquation se
faisait pas et sinon en comité on a une
succession de témoins qui tous l'un
après l'autre n'ont pas été capable de
beaucoup nous en apprendre davantage
donc j'ai l'impression Daniel que il y a
pas tant de choses qu'on a appris sur ce
dossier là c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
comment le rapport le comité tout ça
est-ce qu'on a l'impression d'être vous
avez l'impression d'être un peu mieux
éclairé que la semaine dernière
je dirais que j'ai appris que j'étais
moins cette semaine que je savais la
semaine dernière ou que je croyais à
savoir la semaine dernière
je dirais comme pour débuter la clé que
vous avez montré de Justin Trudeau c'est
le premier ministre il y aide de
remettre l'enjeu en étant une question
d'ingérence chinoise auprès des
élections et de
questionnements au sujet de qu'est-ce
que les autorités qu'est-ce que la scars
savait qu'est-ce que le commissaire des
élections Canada savait mais c'est pas
vraiment ça la question la question qui
est sortie avec les fuites dans les
médias c'est qu'est-ce que Justin
Trudeau savait de l'ingérence chinoise
est-ce que le Parti libéral savait que
la sars leur avait mentionné ou avait
reçu de l'intelligence disant qu'il y
avait des candidats au moins un
peut-être d'autres
qui étaient influencés par le
gouvernement chinois est-ce qu'il savait
qu'il y avait de l'argent du
gouvernement chinois qui semble
nous allons le reportage dans le groupe
email et avec global TV se rendre dans
les poches de certains contribuables
qu'ils ont en retour donné au parti
libérales c'est question là que les gens
ont pis ces questions-là n'ont pas été
répondu cette semaine mais je dirais
qu'on a eu plus d'informations sur
comment traiter l'information de ces
fuites là alors je serais joli tendresse
qui est la sécurité nationale du Premier
ministre et puis monsieur morestine qui
est le sous-ministre aux Affaires
étrangères qui avait siéger sur ce qui
était là en 2021 au sujet de savoir si
la gérance à quel point les bureaux 4
devait le dire au Canadien
eux ils nous ont illuminé un peu plus
sur les fuites alors c'est
l'intelligence qu'on reçoit des services
comme la sars c'est pas une preuve ça
peut vraiment être une rumeur une rumeur
qui nous informe des actions qu'on
devrait peut-être faire comme
gouvernement plus tard mais c'est pas
nécessairement une preuve que la GRC
peut agir dessus c'est pas
nécessairement une preuve que même les
partis politiques peuvent aller alors ça
c'était quand même intéressant
entre un soupçon et une preuve
effectivement Michel est-ce que est-ce
que Monsieur Trudeau l'a bien le bien
joué cette semaine est-ce qu'il s'en est
bien sorti comment votre évaluation de
sa façon de gérer cette crise là
attendez de vous dire comme d'habitude
il a mal géré sa crise
d'abord on peut pas nous donner un
rapport comme ils l'ont fait en disant
ça n'atteint pas le degré suffisant pour
dire que l'élection pouvait être
entachée puis pas dire c'est quoi le
niveau de preuve qu'il faut pour ça un
moment donné nous on a un niveau de
preuve secret pour vous dire pas c'est
quoi mon dire on sait pas manger ça
marche pas deuxièmement il y a pas de
petite cloche qui sonne au bureau du
premier ministre quand il va nommer
comme président de ce comité-là une
personne qui pourrait être nommée dans
un conflit d'intérêts potentiels
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui a été
président de la Fondation Trudeau et à
chaque fois qu'il y a une crise à gérer
on dirait que la petite sonnette
d'alarme qui devrait partir au bureau du
premier ministre ça n'existe pas et
c'est d'autant et ça c'est multiplié par
le fait que Monsieur Trudeau chaque fois
qu'il est question de la Chine semble
avoir ne pas avoir les repères habituels
puis pas être capable de les phrases
complètes qui fait d'habitude alors
mettez tout ça ensemble on finit la
semaine je pense du côté du Premier
ministre plus bas qu'il a commencé puis
c'est essentiellement ça faut et oui
elle tient ouais mais juste pour
préciser parce que vendredi le Premier
ministre nous en fait mentionner que
Monsieur Rosenberg avait été le choix de
la fonction publique
ça veut pas dire que peut-être les gens
dans le premier dans le bureau du
premier ministre aurait pas dû dire ben
peut-être que ce monsieur là on devrait
peut-être pas le nommer à cause de son
rôle avec la formation Trudeau mais
c'est quand même c'était pas un choix du
gouvernement libéral comme tel c'est
intéressant quand même que ça le prix 5
jours avant de sortir cette nouvelle là
et juste auprès du seuil qu'on doit
atteindre le seuil il est très élevé
mais il est défini est-ce que
l'ingérence aurait changé le résultat de
l'élection comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
ce point-là franchement je sais pas il
semble que les gens qui les 16
bureaucratent
pas non plus nécessairement mais on nous
a informé cette semaine à travers le
témoignages au comité parlementaire que
ils avaient pas juste regardé auprès du
concours national mais dans tous les
compter aussi alors il y a quand même un
soupçon qui est surtout sorti du parti
Constantin qui avait des comptes qui
avaient été affectés mais là on nous dit
monsieur Maurice a témoigné que eux ils
ne croivent pas qu'il y a un concours à
travers le pays qui a été affecté que si
les gouvernement chinois aurait pas agi
ça leur fait une différence
le gouvernement qui doit gagner et soit
capable de effectivement influencer une
élection aussi influence étrangère c'est
zéro et on accepte pas qu'il y en ait
c'est ça aussi le critère il y a eu 9 10
11 députés qui ont vu de l'influence
chinoise à leur compter ces troubles et
est-ce qu'on a besoin de dire moi
j'aurais perdu mon élection je regagne
mon élector si ça n'avait pas été ça ça
devrait pas être écrit par l'autre
élément qui a beaucoup quand on a
beaucoup parlé cette semaine Fanny c'est
l'idée d'une enquête publique tout le
monde a l'air de vouloir une enquête
publique à Ottawa sauf le gouvernement
libéral qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
comprenez
la commission rouleau qui était une
enquête publique nous a quand même
prouvé que même si certaines
informations restent secrètes même si
des documents restaient classifiés on en
a quand même appris beaucoup ça a quand
même permis de jeter la lumière de
vraiment révéler comment s'est passé
toutes ces périodes qu'on voit des
camionnettes donc ça nous a fait la
preuve qu'on peut quand même apprendre
des choses à ce point-ci même si le doc
le public n'aurait pas accès aux
documents classifié le juge lui ou le
commissaire indépendant lui pourrait y
avoir accès elle étudie les documents et
ensuite venir nous en parler et jeter un
peu son regard sur ce qu'il a pu voir à
ce point-ci le problème c'est que les
gens perdent complètement confiance en
ce processus électoral il y a un sondage
pas plus tard que cette semaine qui est
révélé que pas moins de 23% des
Canadiens pensent que l'élection a été
volée par la Chine c'est pas rien c'est
près d'un corps des Canadiens d'un quart
des répondants alors il y a il y a un
vrai danger d'une désaffectation
désaffections du public et on a vu aux
États-Unis les dangers que peuvent avoir
les les perceptions que le
que les élections ont été truquées ont
été volés c'est dangereux alors à ce
point-ci s'ils ne choisit pas de faire
une élection une enquête il doit au
moins agir et montrer qu'il est proactif
et ensuite Michel quel est le risque
pour Monsieur Trudeau de ce camper sur
la position qu'il entretient depuis la
semaine dernière Michel
souvenez-vous du scandale des
commandites il n'était pas question que
le gouvernement libéral fort une
commission d'enquête là-dessus on avait
tous les renseignements dans ton on
avait besoin et bon ça a pris un
remplacement de Premier ministre vous me
direz mais à un moment donné pas le
matin qui savait très bien ce qui allait
arriver s'il y avait si créer à la
commission Gomery a été obligé de la
créer quand même alors actuellement le
feu est sous la marmite là combien de
temps ça va prendre avant quelques
qu'elle soit ébullition on verra mais
quand tous les partis d'opposition quand
à peu près toutes les pages
d'historiales de journal de journaux
canadiens que j'ai pu lire il faut une
enquête publique là-dessus ça fait
comment ça commence à faire pas mal de
pression on verra jusqu'où ça aboutira
mais à un moment donné et probable qu'on
se retrouve avec une commission en
quelques secondes parce que je veux
passer à l'autre sujet mais en quelques
secondes est-ce que le gouvernement peut
tenir ce point de vue là très longtemps
on connaît madame Anderson on connaît
les idées qu'elle a mis de l'avant
monsieur Poyer c'est a pris ses
distances
et qui elle tient la route ça s'excuse
là
dans une seule circonstance c'est à dire
que quand le téléphone ne s'est député
là ont été utilisés pour enlever TikTok
qui ont aussi enlever Google parce que
ça prend pas une personne qui est dans
la vie publique une personne qui est
dans la vie publique on peut facilement
trouver qui c'est un peu quel est son
curriculum vitalité ça prend très
exactement
alors un moment donné dire ah non je le
savais pas dans la liste des excuses
c'est juste après le chien manger mon
devoir ça ne tient pas la route ça n'a
pas de sens et il va falloir là-dessus
que Monsieur poignet soit beaucoup plus
sévère avec ses députés parce qu'il y a
quand même une perception que depuis
monsieur poignet les idées plus à droite
pour ne pas dire d'extrême droite en
plus la vague aux parties conservateurs
ça ça peut être très dangereux pour
Monsieur polyèvre alors il faut vraiment
que qui sifflent de la récréation on
sait depuis le début on dit ouais mais
je croyais il flirtent quand même un peu
avec cette tranche là est-ce que il y a
de la est-ce qu'il va trop loin est-ce
que c'est danger
je voudrais dire au sujet de la député
allemande
c'était
ces mots sur les anti-vacs qui les
intéressait c'était pas ces positions
sur l'immigration ou d'autres enjeux
c'était vraiment ils l'ont rencontré
parce que c'est un groupe de trois
députés très très con de la vaccination
les mandats de vaccination et puis c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont rencontré mais je
suis d'accord avec Michel c'est pas
crédible de dire qu'il savait pas quoi
d'autre qu'avaient autour de cette
députés là mais je pense que ça peut
nuire à Monsieur poilliev parce que
Maxime Bernier est déjà en train de de
l'attaquer en disant que c'est pas une
personne critique qui est pas qui est
pas là pour vous puis c'est elle-même
problème que Monsieur un auto l'avait
puis je pense que ça pourrait être un
problème pour Monsieur
polliathlon absolument justement ça me
faisait penser à une entrevue qui avait
une auto l'avait accordé à politico il y
a quelques semaines où il disait que il
croyait qu'il avait perdu la confiance
de son focus spécifiquement à cause et
que de plus en plus députés sont prêts
de complotisme alors c'est un problème
Karine auto l'avait sur les bras c'est
un problème que Pierre pollen aura aussi
sur les bras à la différence que lui a
peut-être un peu flirté avec les
théories du complot pendant la course au
lieu de Chypre conservateur alors il
doit marcher sur une ligne très mince
pour éviter dans de d'amener de l'eau au
moulin à ceux qui le dénoncent et éviter
aussi d'amener l'eau du lundi
complètement
Fanny ALTHIA Michel merci d'avoir été là
Fanny je vous retrouve un petit peu plus
tard devant l'émission merci à vous
trois
au revoir